i do believe that mr martin um
has a surprise for the audience here
sir is it a surprise it is they don't
know they don't know
okay i thought i'd read you a little of
the winds of winter
just a little
i don't have time to do a whole chapter
here but i'll read you the beginning of
uh
of a chapter
what a thrill
i just heard somebody say i want to hear
it but i don't want to hear it
[Laughter]
now if you haven't read uh if you
haven't read all the books up to and
including a dance with dragons you might
want to leave because
this takes up right
right where the dance of dragons leaves
off it takes off of like like five
minutes after the end of a dance with
dragons so uh
um
brace yourself you'll be right in the
middle of it here
victarion
the noble lady was a tub of a ship as
fat and wallowing as the noble ladies of
the green lands her holds were huge and
victarion packed them with armed men
with her would sail the other lesser
prizes that the iron fleet had taken on
his long voyage to slavers bay a lubbery
assortment of cogs great cogs carracks
and trading galleys salted here and
there with fishing boats
it was a fleet both fat and feeble
promising much in the way of wool and
wines and other trade goods and little
in the way of danger
victarion gave the command of it to wolf
one ear
the slavers may shiver when they spy
your sails rising from the sea he told
him but once they see you playing they
will laugh at their fears
traitors and fishers that's all you are
any man can see that let them get close
as they like but keep your men hidden
below ducks until you're ready then
close and board them free the slaves and
feed the slavers to the sea but take the
ships
we will have need of every hull to carry
us back home
home
wolf grinned the men will like the sound
of that lord captain
the ships first then we break these
junkish men
i
the iron victory was lashed alongside
the noble lady the two ships bound tight
with chains and grappling hooks a ladder
stretched between them the great cog was
much larger than the warship and sat
higher in the water all along the gun
walls the faces of the ironborn peered
down watching as victarion clapped wolf
one air on the shoulder and sent him
clambering up the ladder the sea was
smooth and still the sky bright with
stars
wolf watered the ladder drawn up the
chains cast off
the warship in the cog parted ways
in the distance the rest of victarion's
feigned fleet was raising sail
a ragged chair went up from the crew of
the iron victory and was answered in
kind by the men of the noble lady
victarion had given wolf his best
fighters
he envied them they would be the first
to strike a blow the first to see that
look of fear in the fomen's eyes
as he stood at the prowl of the iron
victory watching one ears merchant ships
vanish one by one into the west
the faces of the first foe he'd ever
slain came back to victorian greyjoy
he thought of his first ship
of his first woman
a restlessness was in him a hunger for
the dawn and the things this day would
bring
death or glory i will drink my fill of
both today
the seastone chair should have been his
when balan died but his brother euron
had stolen it from him just as he had
stolen his wife many years before he
stole her and he soiled her but he left
it for me to slay her
all that was done and gone now though
victarion would have his due at last
i have the horn and soon i will have the
woman a woman lovelier than the wife he
made me kill
captain
the voice belonged to long water pike
the oarsmen await your pleasure
three of them and strong ones
send them to my cabin
i want the priest as well
the oarsmen were all big
one was a boy
one a brute
one of bastard's bastard
the boy had been rowing for less than a
year the brute for twenty
they had names but victorian did not
know them one had come from lamentation
one from sparrowhawk one from
spider-kiss he could not be expected to
know the names of every thrall who had
ever pulled an oar in the iron fleet
show them the horn he commanded when the
three had been ushered into his cabin
mokoro brought it forth and the dusky
woman lifted up a lantern to give them
all a look
in the shifting lantern light the
hellhorn seemed to writhe and turn into
priests hands like a serpent fighting to
escape
makoro was a man of monstrous size big
bellied broad-shouldered towering but
even in his grasp the horn looked huge
my brother found this thing on valeria
victorian throw the thralls
think how big the dragon must have been
to bear two of these upon his head
bigger than vegar or meroxies bigger
than blarion the black dread
he took the horn from makoro and ran his
palm along his curves
at the kingsmoot on old wick one of
euron's mutes blew upon this horn some
of you will remember
it was not a sound that any man who
heard it will ever forget
they say he died the boy said him who
blew the horn
i
the horn was smoking after
the mute had blisters on his lips and
the bird inked across his chest was
bleeding
he died the next day and they cut him
open his lungs were black
the horn is cursed said the bastards
bastard
a dragon's horn from valeria said
victorian hi it's cursed i never said it
wasn't
he brushed his hand across one of the
red gold bands and the ancient glyph
seemed to sing beneath his fingertips
for half a heartbeat he wanted nothing
so much as to sound the horn himself
euron was a fool to give me this it is a
precious thing and powerful with this
i'll win the seastone chair and then the
iron throne
with this i'll win the world
clagor and blew the horn thrice and died
for it he was as big as any of you and
strong as me so strong that he could
twist a man's head right off his
shoulders with only his bare hands and
yet the horn killed him
it will kill us too then said the boy
victorian did not all forgive a thrall
for talking out of turn but the boy was
young no more than 20 and soon to die
besides he let it pass
the mute sounded the horn three times
you three will sound it only once
might be you'll die
might be you won't
all men die
the iron fleet is sailing into battle
many on this very ship will be dead
before the sun goes down stabbed or
slashed gutted drowned burned alive only
the gods know which of us will still be
here come tomorrow
sound the horn and live and i'll make
free men of you
one or two or all three i'll give you
wives a bit of land a ship to sail
thralls of your own men will know your
names
even you lord captain as the bastards
bastard
i i'll do it then
and me said the boy
the brute crossed his arms and nodded
if it made the three feel braver to
believe they had a choice let them cling
to that victarion kid little what they
believed they were only thralls
you will sail with me on iron victory
you told them but you will not join the
battle
boy you're the youngest you'll sound the
horn first
when the time comes you will blow it
long and loud they say you're strong
blow the horn until you are too weak to
stand until the last bit of breath has
been squeezed from you until your lungs
are burning let the freedmen hear you in
marine slavers in yunkai the ghosts and
astapor let the monkeys [ __ ] themselves
at the sound when it rolls across the
isle of cedars
then pass the horn along to the next man
do you hear me do you know what to do
the boy and the bastard bastards tug
their
the brute might have done the same but
he was bald
he may touch the horn then go
they left him one by one the three
thralls and then makoto
victorian would not let him take the
hellhorn i will keep it here with me
until it's needed
as you command
would you have me bleed you
victorian seized a dusky woman by the
wrist and pulled her to him she will do
it go pray to your red god
light your fire
and tell me what you see
makoto's dark eyes seem to shine
i see dragons
wow
just a taste
just a taste